[Música]
hoy 2 de noviembre se conmemora el día
internacional contra la impunidad de los
crímenes contra nosotros los periodistas
la jornada va acompañada de un informe
de la unesco que reporta la violencia
contra la profesión en los últimos cinco
años se registraron 400 asesinatos de
periodistas en todo el mundo con una
tasa de impunidad del
87 por ciento para ello quiero darle la
bienvenida a nuestro primer invitado el
día del ex william canela jefe del área
de libertad de expresión y seguridad de
periodistas de la unesco killer gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 es que las cifras
son alarmantes entre 2006 y 2020 más de
1200 periodistas fueron asesinados según
la unesco también 9 de cada 10 casos
siguen sin resolverse judicialmente qué
está pasando con esto por qué tanta
impunidad contra los periodistas
hola muy buenos días a ustedes buenas
tardes acá desde oslo y noruega donde
estamos de hecho discutiendo esta
cuestión con varios especialistas de
distintas partes del mundo y el rastro
tiene toda la razón raúl son datos
alarmantes el creciente volumen de
ataques contra la libertad de expresión
en general y contra la libertad de
prensa en particular si bien hay un dato
positivo en este informe de la unesco
que tenemos que subrayar y hasta
celebrar una reducción del 20 por ciento
en los asesinatos contra periodistas en
relación a los cinco años anteriores
todos los otros tipos de ataques
crecieron o sea prisiones arbitrarias lo
que llamamos de acoso judicial y sobre
todos los ataques en línea
particularmente contra mujeres
periodistas y lo que está pasando es una
realidad compleja o sea distintos
elementos contribuyen para explicar eso
pero en parte es que los ustedes
periodistas siguen haciendo su trabajo
siguen investigando corrupción siguen
investigando
violaciones de derechos humanos siguen
investigando crímenes ambientales y
estas cosas molestan a los poderosos y
ahí hay una reacción como esta es que
estamos viviendo de ataques contra los y
las periodistas ahora geller hablamos de
los premios nobel de paz que
precisamente este año fueron dos
periodistas a la muela filipina maría
reza y el ruso dmitri murátov qué
significa esto para el gremio
periodístico y también para esas
personas que pues sienten miedo e
inseguridad al hacer al hacer sus
profesiones como una manera también de
envalentonar no sé decir sigan adelante
que lo que están haciendo está correcto
sin duda importante también subrayar
particularmente en el contexto
colombiano que maría reza había ya
ganado el premio guillermo cano unesco
mundial de libertad de prensa en mayo de
este año
y anna politovskaya del diario de lo
cual
dmitri es miembro había ganado este
mismo premio guillermo cánones con unos
años antes y sin duda este
reconocimiento internacional a las
personas a estos y a estas periodistas
en particular pero sobre todo al
periodismo como una institución clave
para la democracia y para la paz es
fundamental es fundamental para una
protección de la profesión en general
pero también como un estímulo a las
nuevas generaciones de periodistas que
esta institución sigue siendo central
para la democracia y para el estado de
derecho y esta fue la mensaje del comité
del nobel cuando ganador no el premio a
rezaí amor o todos subrayaron de manera
muy clara la importancia del periodismo
para
y eso sin duda es un elemento importante
para crear conciencia en toda la
sociedad que un ataque a un periodista
no es sólo un ataque este individuo es
un ataque a toda la sociedad si no
tenemos eso en cuenta las tasas de
impunidad no van a bajar ahora aguilera
américa latina' lamentablemente sigue
siendo la región más peligrosa para
ejercer el periodismo para ejercer esta
profesión no para decir la verdad
buscarla además le digo méxico sigue
también siendo el país más violento en
los últimos días también han sido
asesinados periodistas porque esta
violencia en américa latina y porque
méxico sigue siendo el país más inseguro
para ejercer la profesión
los datos de la unesco han demostrado
que en los últimos años hay un cambio en
relación a la violencia contra los y las
periodistas particularmente lo que se
refiere a los asesinatos antes los los
datos demostraban que la mayoría de los
periodistas eran asesinados en zonas de
conflicto armados y lo que está pasando
que los últimos años son justamente los
periodistas como yo mencionaba antes que
están haciendo la cobertura diaria la
cobertura del crimen organizado en las
fronteras del país la cobertura de los
casos de corrupción de corrupción
policial de corrupción de los políticos
en particular o de violaciones de
derechos humanos de crímenes ambientales
son aquellos que son más blancos de este
tipo de violencia y claro que en el
contexto latinoamericano los asesinatos
están muy relacionados al crimen
organizado y eso explica y mucho en esta
situación de la región y por eso también
en el positivo hay un trabajo muy fuerte
en la región para intentar contrarrestar
esta realidad por ejemplo con la unesco
y los poderes judiciales y los
ministerios públicos las fiscalías de
toda américa latina estamos en un
trabajo bastante fuerte de formación de
fiscales y jueces sobre esta temática
porque eso es central para combatir la
impunidad que los sistemas de justicia
entiendan la particularidad de
investigar crímenes contra periodistas
que leerán por ultimar que preguntarse
esa cifra del 87 el 87 por ciento de
impunidad en las muertes de los
periodistas va a incrementar o se puede
reducir
hay una hay una pequeña buena noticia y
que en el informe anterior era 90% o sea
bajamos un poco y creo que está
relacionado a esta a este a esta
política global de naciones unidas- de
unesco pero también la política regional
de organizaciones como la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos y
etcétera de hacer mucho hincapié en que
combatir la impunidad es fundamental
para parar con el ciclo de la violencia
entonces bajamos 3 por ciento es poco
necesitamos mucho más pero hay acá una
un faro de esperanza de que eso puede
mejorar en los próximos años pero para
eso necesitamos el involucramiento de
todos estos actores particularmente los
actores del sistema de justicia